even vladingerbrook is a Dutch legal
philosopher who lives in the middle of a
society in Europe that's being
transformed by the climate agenda Eva
appreciate your coming on tonight is it
clear to people in Europe that this is
just a straight out power play by the
Chinese government to displace the West
no not clear enough I'm afraid I I don't
think that they see through the real
agenda behind this and obviously you
know these people know only how to rule
by fear so what is happening is not just
China but also our government officials
you know our Elites obviously benefit
from a fearful Society from fearful
people people are afraid that the world
is going to end because what is a better
way to get people to comply to the
things that you say that they have to do
than by you know having them actually
fare for their lives you know that's
always the globalist's tragedy we've
seen it with covet but the climate is
probably even more effective because
well if you really believe that the
world is going to end you know what is
there that you wouldn't do in order to
save the planet and so that strategy of
creating a crisis you know of saying
well we have an emergency and it needs
to be solved now we are on thin ice
we're all going to die you know that's
incredibly effective and the solution
that they always present you with is
that we us ordinary people have to give
up our rights our property and our
freedom in order to solve this so-called
crisis you know it's always a rules for
thee but not for me type of situation
that is why we are the only ones that
will end up not eating meat not flying
anymore not being allowed to drive our
cars but for them nothing ever changes
I just got to wonder how the people who
are pushing this and I think some of
them are doing it in good faith I think
they're really afraid the end of the
world is coming and they blame
themselves but how do they explain China
building two new coal plants a week why
is that cool in a world in which
carbon dioxide is considered poison
right well you can't explain it right so
that shows you that there is a different
agenda behind this you know you can't
argue with these people uh rationally
really and the fact that you can't you
know the fact that for example in the
Netherlands you know you've all seen
what happens to or what is happening to
our Dutch Farmers we are such a tiny
little country yet our government says
that we are the biggest nitrogen
pollution polluter in the world and that
all of our Farms need to be gone by 2030
uh to to solve this so-called crisis you
know and Germany for example is not even
subjected to those rules so all of this
is completely arbitrary so we need to
think past the lies that they are trying
to sell us you know we need to wake up
to the real agenda behind this and that
is well I'm sad to say it but very
simple one it's always about money and
it's always about power
when they tell you to get rid of your
Farms I think that's a red flag I don't
think I'm paranoid I think that's that's
fair you prefer doing your book great to
see you tonight thank you
thank you Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight